you teased to us before that you might
be rocking some leather what is it yes
yes look at this look leather silver i i
don't know with black trim i just saw
the pattern and i liked it so i said
that's that's the one i'm gonna roll
with and you won't be in it for long
because you've got quite a few outfit
changes tonight right after this red
carpet this thing's coming off it's not
coming it's kind of comfortable but i
wouldn't want to be in this thing longer
than about half hour and then on to
outfit number two now tonight you are a
triple threat you have a lot of duties
coming up including hosting how are you
feeling now that the big night is
finally here i'm excited you know it's
uh it's it's time everything we've been
preparing for the last couple months and
yesterday with rehearsal and today we
did a full rehearsal so it's been good
it's been fun what can fans expect from
you gabby and dolly uh you know they can
expect uh
i have no idea
but just expect it's gonna be two hours
that's for sure it's gonna be a lot of
music now now is the family here with
you i know you've got your beautiful
wife it's date night i'm here having my
mom it's her birthday today uh so uh so
it's a good day my father-in-law is here
uh yes good day and the babies are back
home in nashville raven's home in
nashville with alex's mom my
mother-in-law and my sister and stuff so
they're hanging out well congratulations
because you're now a father of three how
is everything doing
your latest baby gave us a little scare
is she okay she's good you know we went
from man-to-man to zone coverage once we
had that third one and uh it's a big
jump people talk about well yeah two
three is not a lot it is going from two
to three is a big jump but it's cool uh
we love them and uh just we're
definitely thankful for our kids do you
and aiden feel a little outnumbered oh
for sure we definitely feel that number
right you know
yeah
we are got another boy up in that family
oh i'm done i'm done i retired my jersey
how does your wife feel about that she's
okay with it okay yeah we you know we
threw around the idea of maybe
having another one by like four years
thought about it tossed around we tossed
around the idea and then closed the idea
and then closed the idea exactly well
you have a beautiful family you are
blessed beyond belief and
congratulations on everything thank you
so great
[Music]